[Music]
welcome back to care for boys where we
are currently off the record
and uh
on the record i had this actually
written down last night i thought there
would be some really great answers for
this
what is something
that you wish jk fans all knew something
that they all knew because they you know
like it's it's hard to
there's a lot of things that are hard to
explain
but what's something that you wish
[ __ ] work goes into this goddamn job
they'll never appreciate it sometimes
that leave just mentally exhausted i
think this shit's easy you think this
shit's real simple or something this is
a party
do you think we're just sitting here
just [ __ ] cracking jokes all day just
farting around huh what do you think
this is i feel like every time i watch a
celebrity try to talk about how hard
they work like the instant reaction is
just like oh [ __ ] off
i roll yeah i think so too but we work
so hard in here dude i will say one and
we're celebrities i will say that one
thing from my perspective coming in like
much later yeah is that i wish that uh
that that people that are watching jk
knew that how much we actually care
about it being good you know like
because there is a lot of like uh time
being spent on that a lot of effort of
like you know it sucks when people will
look at it and just compare lifetime
stats of the channel because that
doesn't make sense to me it's like uh
you know if if you could just see the
channel as like a like if it was a new
fledgling thing even though it's like a
new era i look at it like it's a new
channel it's not the same from when i
first started watching it i mean we've
been online for 15 years i mean jk news
alone is probably over a decade now
right but just
i had so many different channels that um
it all felt like one though you know
what i mean like it's like
i've been on youtube with different
channels it's been a different part of
me because different channels express
different ideas or whatever but it all
feels like one way of connecting with
people yeah yeah and so like
yeah there's been
channels that shut down there's like
different content we don't do anymore
but it's just like a gateway to connect
with the people
that are like-minded or enjoy our jokes
or whatever yeah dude i've i've been on
you just made me do some math i'm like
holy [ __ ] i've been on youtube for like
13 years whoa
you guys have been out for 50 years
you're a junior high kid yeah yeah
[ __ ] wild i guess one thing i wish
that people knew
uh would be
like
i wouldn't say the ingredients or the
formula but something along those lines
of how we approach
making stuff like for example right um i
think people that have had really tight
friends
they when they see that like we roast
each other they're like okay i totally
get how tight they really are and
they're really good friends with each
other but then the people that haven't
experienced that themselves they might
actually think that like we bully
anthony or whatever right and then so we
all hate it so people they like they
feel that yeah they say excuse me
like they'll fill them with their own
blanks do you know what i mean so i
think that part where it's because like
when we have a ton of fun and we're
having like this boys locker room type
of fun right we want everyone along for
the ride right but then if you haven't
experienced it then you're like well
that's weird and then you fill in your
own blanks with what you know but you
don't know that how much more fun it is
like
once you go from like junior high
basketball to varsity basketball you
know and then you're like oh that's the
real fun over there so i think that's
like sometimes i wish i'm like oh man
you guys aren't there yet but i'll be
cool because then once you are you'll
understand like how much fun and how
much you really care about it and also
just for the sake of laughs
how sometimes obviously this is the most
obvious [ __ ] we should say but we
purposely
say something opposite because yeah
making each other laugh and having a
good time
is more fun than saying what the obvious
should have been except for when you
talk about women what do you mean he
just says real [ __ ]
he says well we're all thinking yeah so
i dude i came up in a big family so like
roasting is just what you do and that's
how i show affection until i feel
affection nikki roasts me more than
anybody in the [ __ ] world other than
you guys yeah so but i love it she also
sucks your dick more than anyone else
someone makes
i think there's a lot to be said about
that too in like uh like when when i
would see comments and i realized i
didn't understand this because i hadn't
thought about it forever but like when
someone's like dude where's the sausage
fest it's all guys where's the girls
it's like i realized that too that for a
long time i went through life wanting to
always see girls like i want to see
girls want to hang out with girls but a
lot of people don't realize that as you
get older it's really [ __ ] hard to
get together with your boys it's super
[ __ ]
super rare that's really true just have
something like this be like a regular
thing is like that's a that's really big
for male mental health honestly even
last night when i was a little bit
touched i'm not gonna lie uh i'll admit
it because um we all went out after and
uh after jk it was really fun that's
some korean baba cow but anthony said
something that i honestly thought about
a couple times and i'll just admit it it
was you said well it'll be it'll it's
great so like when steve's here we can
all go out after and i was like i like i
love that we we feel like we're a group
like that it's not just like
you know i don't know i i i'm glad and
if steve's not here everyone's like [ __ ]
off just lie to me just lie to me just
lie to me say you don't hang just lie to
me but i like that we have you know the
careful boys yeah
it's dope it does get super difficult
that's the thing it's like and if any of
you guys are young like just take don't
take that for granted like it's going to
be super hard to see your friends as you
get older and busier just hanging out
with friends is just difficult just
being in a group
and just chilling till like two in the
morning talking in the parking lot that
[ __ ] doesn't happen anymore and if it
does you're a [ __ ] loser bro
well this is the part of life too
because we're like all 30s so it's like
this is the part of life where you're
friends
um you you go you transition from your
friends become your family do you start
to build your own family too so it's
really cool that we still have like that
friend bond even though
we're at this point i think um i don't
know if it was like an elevator pitch or
like a a slogan for the friends tv show
but it was like something about like uh
that point in your life when your
friends or your family yeah for sure oh
yeah i think that happens in your 20s a
lot of the times yeah slowly building at
that point you have a big crew
i would love jk fans to know um
really how much because maybe there's
just not so many obvious times to say it
but how much they've even personally had
an impact on my own life and career
because even before like as a dancer
like my content creation is just like
choreographed dance routines or
freestyle just stuff right it's such a
unique expression even for me my my
random split personality in that sense
like i get to be a fool when i'm talking
but when i'm dancing and choreographing
it's such like a unspoken part of myself
so it usually gets really serious or
ethereal or deep or something like that
i'm trying to express something that i
don't know how to put into words why
don't you do funny dances
i do i do thanks for subscribing um but
uh
but here i get to be something
i get to be myself and i get to express
it and speak that and the amount of
uh because jk's way bigger than the kid
just so the amount of like fans that
have been able to come over even to like
my kinder's ecosystem and support and
understand me for who i am in that space
has really i think um i'm gonna say [ __ ]
kendra's yes
evolved and just even matured you know
like who i am as a person or as a
content creator and stuff like that too
so like jk fans have had a huge impact
on like my own career yeah i'll
piggyback on that too because i'm
obviously really new to this space i've
never like
done anything like this before i never
thought i would do anything like this
before
so like random people will just come up
to me and be like hey
you're on jk news and
i'm sure you're the angry guy yeah
you're the guy that hates everything and
uh i'm sure like my wife has been there
too and seen those interactions and she
goes why are you so weird
and i go what are you talking about
right and then she goes well like
people come up to you and like you get
really uncomfortable
and you have to be like
kind of very nice like when they say hi
to you yeah because i get kind of caught
off guard and you know he says no autos
no [ __ ] pics
no [ __ ] way because what i want to do
like in my in my body i go i just want
like oh cool thank you like and i just
want to [ __ ] leave because it makes
me feel uncomfortable but but i am very
thankful for all the love and there's
been a lot of people that have like
sent me comments and like i've never
experienced that before and that's been
really cool too and kind of like
the people coming up to you and the
support that you get from like random
people that don't even know you that's
been really new to me and that's been
really eye-opening like oh [ __ ] like the
internet is a [ __ ] crazy place you
know i told you guys off camera i don't
know if i said this on camera but the
day that you guys were even willing to
ask me when we were doing that off the
record and we were talking about kenji
bang noodles first getting on to like
amazon and costco and stuff like that
was actually our biggest sale a sale day
on amazon and amazon like hit us up and
was just like yo what did you guys do
and i had no idea what was going on
right steve roasted me for 20 minutes
yeah
well i can't believe how genius the
marketing is throwing throwing our
noodles in the trash can he works in
mysterious ways dude but but just you
know as much as it's a roast or a joke
like the fact that the fans came out you
fans you know like supported and stuff
like that crypto corn was buying
or they were they were saying they were
buying they were buying your [ __ ] the
whole time they're buying your [ __ ] the
whole time
i think that's the coolest part though
is like all the years that we've been
on youtube right there's different eras
of fans too because i'll be at the gym
or whatever there's a [ __ ] grown
grown-ass dude just staring at me and
i'm all like man she's gonna [ __ ] hit
on me or something right and he goes hey
man i used to watch you when i was a kid
man
i'm like 30 years old now i used to
watch you when i was little and i was
like oh [ __ ] 15 years ago oh [ __ ] that
is true you were like a [ __ ] high
school kid or whatever you know like and
then so you tell me it's okay to jack
off a lot
[Laughter]
it's okay to get your [ __ ] eating
it's cool you made it really cool but
then there's like
people that still watch now there's
people who watched when it was jk films
there was it's and then there's just
like and they don't they don't know that
we had jk party or whatever right or
there's people that just watch party and
then there's just so many different
people that
had enjoyment just from our content that
we made and i'm just like constantly
reminded like oh [ __ ] yeah we did do
that channel didn't we because sometimes
i'm like we only do jk news
and i totally forget that we did
sketches today's video is brought to you
by audible all right i've been using
audible for quite some time now and
especially it's really really good for
road trips especially now that i live in
vegas is the main reason why i use it
when you're on the road for four hours
so bart suggested me to go check out one
of this book it's called psychology of
money um i like it and it helped me out
a lot especially after i lost a million
dollars in luna i said man i need i need
to really get my life together because i
gotta stop being a d gen with the way
that i manage myself and this book was
perfect because i got to sit and and not
get distracted and just really learn and
get like involved with everything that
the author was saying because
when you're in a car and listening to
something i think like you have no other
distractions but the road so it really
helps me just like focus and it's one of
the best ways that i like to learn and
if you're new to audible they're really
cool they are your one-stop shop for
your audio entertainment so they got
podcasts audio books shows like all of
that and every month you get a brand new
credit so you can check out a different
book every single month let audible help
you discover new ways to laugh be
inspired
or be entertained new members can try it
free for 30 days visit audible.com off
the record or text off the record to
500-500 that's audible.com off the
record or text off the record to 500 500
to try audible for free for 30 days
audible.com off the record this always
happens too i'm sure you guys know like
it's like oh man i was all so sad i was
about to kill myself and [ __ ] and then
like when i watch your video i laugh so
hard i forgot to kill myself
and i'm like
that happens to so many people on
youtube where people walk up to them
they're like i'm about to kill myself
and i'm like it's very common right like
how many suicides has youtubers stopped
or is it the same guy that almost killed
himself he's going to all these meetings
and he's like i don't know who's going
to stop me today
he subscribed to a lot of channels right
yeah yeah because i swear to god every
single youtuber has a story of somebody
preventing suicide yeah that guy sucks
at killing himself he's like at the edge
of the building and right before he's
going to jump
some youtube videos right here yeah
what's up my algorithm
i always want one more
one more this time
i guess i won't jump today because i
thought about it too because i thought
like when we first got into this we
wanted to do entertainment we were like
let's [ __ ] go you know then we're
building a big ass [ __ ] following
money everything and we're just like
oh my god this is amazing and then
after a while it's like all those things
that are novelty like
seeing large numbers
um on the view count or maybe like those
zeros in your bank account or whatever
it actually gets it's really quick how
fast it desensitized desensitized me of
like um i didn't care about that [ __ ] no
more so then after a while i was like
what would keep me going on creating
content and it's one it's like being in
an environment like this
where
like you're right we can't meet up and
just hang like every you need a reason
to hang so you need to do it behind a
purpose like hey we're doing work so we
have to get with the boys and talk right
but then
when i foresee saw that in the future i
was like the only way we can stay
close friends is is is a really less
than a handful of
things right one would be uh proximity
so the closer you live with someone the
more
you keep them in proximity you hear that
guys
if we all lived on the back of l.a dude
in the same state
that's the closest you can possibly get
if we lived on the same street easily
let's meet up for the weekend let's
[ __ ] have a barbecue real quick i'm
going back home right yeah it's way
easier uh two is like if you work
together you're just in
you know by default because you're there
like you're gonna have more
opportunities to chat [ __ ] water
cooler discussions whatever right but if
you don't have those two things as you
grow you those where you spend most of
your time like in the home and at the
workplace yeah and if you're those are
going to be the people that you spend
the most time with so i always try to
construct businesses around friendships
too because i'm like well i want to
spend more time with these guys so how
do i also not only do that but find a
way where we can all win together and i
think that's that's one of the best ways
to [ __ ] live i think
can't wait to find that way that we're
going to win together yeah when's that
going to happen
one of my favorite things about jk2 is
that like
no matter what the view average is
is you guys have never
not wanted to do it and i think that
means a lot there's some rappers that
won't do the [ __ ] concert unless
there's a specific amount of people in
the audience or if it's gotta be a
[ __ ] packed arena there's like no i'm
not gonna do the show then i need to
know that we're trending down
and that's that's when i'll show up but
that's what that's what's cool about it
is it doesn't matter it's like you're
still speaking to somebody and that's
valuable to a person out there
and that's like that's all it's about
right you know what's telling bart the
other day too i was like we
suck so bad at marketing ourselves just
as everyone here like this dude has a
[ __ ] multi-million channel with
millions of views in his [ __ ] pranks
and [ __ ] you've been in movies this
dude's [ __ ] toured the world with
lmfao [ __ ] you know quest crew you
got the kin just going on i mean you
promote yourself the best actually
everyone here this boy has a [ __ ] you
know gym that's coming up he trains
people all that stuff he was a former
fighter all this [ __ ] right but then
like no one here talks about their thing
like as like people that are marketing
themselves so when we get together it's
just dudes that are just so smart see
that so smart genius but also it goes
against us because if you're tuning in
for the first time it's like who are
these fuckos yeah yeah
that's my favorite also it's my favorite
when you guys bring up some random name
that they've never heard of in their
whole lives and you guys like yeah well
like my friend nick and like
it's not the nick of the room so it's
just like
right
yeah
because i used to come here and then i
would sit here and i'd be like who the
[ __ ] are they talking about and then joe
talks about it through the whole lunch
and i'm like i still know this [ __ ]
guy like funny guys
power rangers in front of yoshi
i didn't know he's a power ranger you
guys didn't tell me he was a blue ranger
and
i think that's what's cool about it
though is like rather than be here to
promote [ __ ] it's like it's cool when
people like my favorite thing is when jk
fans realize that it's almost like a big
brother relationship to them you know
it's like dude if you don't have that
group of friends yourself like you do
have it here in a way like the the
seventh seat is you and you're swiveling
around looking at all of us you know
it's [ __ ] cool i've always felt that
way when i meet supposed to meet people
in public and dude when we were at comic
con i remember telling we we had a bunch
of um people there filming um for the
channel too for like behind the scenes
stuff and i remember telling um
them because i know that people get
weird about maybe meeting someone they
watch a lot
but i was like yo look at how [ __ ]
awkward jk's being they're all in a
[ __ ] circle right there
and they're all like [ __ ] weird and
awkward
and we're the same as you we're not
better than you we're the same as you
like that's that's how we are out and
about too so it's just you know i really
feel that way like i don't feel like i'm
ever better than anybody i always feel
like we if anything we just share
something together and that's why it's
like our our things that we've done in
the past right that's not like who you
identify with right so it's like it's
there but then it's not like when you're
out there and you're promoting yourself
and you're like that's a different kind
of like your marketing you're working
right but when you come here all those
things we kind of throw out the door
it's just a bunch of guys like that are
talking yeah and then i think um doing
that i'm hoping what it does is it
connects to people in a way where
they're like oh these bunch of [ __ ]
losers can't do it i can do it too
exactly honestly that's the best yeah
yeah that's the greatest [ __ ] one of the
things i read uh when we did that video
about like why jk is [ __ ] crumbling
like a [ __ ]
it was so dope dude because the
because the real viewers came out of the
woodwork right they they don't really
comment often but that one had like a
hell of like
600 comments in the first day like
they're just [ __ ] so much support
and it's because i said yo comment like
tell us how you feel and i'm gonna read
that [ __ ] and i did
and one of the things that popped out to
me was all the women that do enjoy just
the guy talk they were saying like it's
like a window into their brothers or
like like how guys really talk without
any women in the room and it's just
unfiltered and it's like it's like that
meme of like i bet he's [ __ ] cheating
and what he's really doing with the boys
is just like stupid she's looking at
bitcoin or something
i think it's because they fantasize
about a sausage fest
they want to be the seventh member right
here right in the middle yeah watch us
deep throat bond me
you know what i wish uh our fans do
because like let's be real guys joe is
[ __ ] insane online but he's actually
a normal cool nice guy
and no one knows honestly when we were
having korean bbq last night because it
was like we're all chatting with joe and
then joe just like yeah so like just
being completely normal and i was like
oh yeah i forgot that's how joey is
like joe's just a normal dude that just
chats he's like how's everything how's
family how's business like and he's not
just being like yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
eating ass man
some people think joey that was a good
joke whoa it was like he was in the room
because i forgot that too when i first
started like guesting on here
i first started guessing on here and
like he's so chilly he's like yeah it's
really easy we'll just hang out and talk
and i was like okay that sounds easy and
as soon as you start mcdonald's in my
[ __ ]
i was like
what the [ __ ]
are we all supposed to talk like that
crazy and it had nothing to do with the
news i was like what did we do
that's another thing dude jk news is my
outlet to let that joe go maybe a little
while boy because then when i'm doing
other parts of my life i got to keep
that one kind of chill you know
i wanted to ask you this i meant to ask
you this a bunch of times uh why are you
like this no kidding no
so ever since we changed because we used
to do show every [ __ ] week right but
ever since the week yeah but ever since
we changed cause i i realized i was like
man jk is a really big part of like my
social like
interactions with like just other humans
other than my wife and like my [ __ ]
kitties especially during the pandemic
um but
did you find yourself like getting all
wound up because i noticed you kind of
you kind of um if you can't like like
share yeah for a certain period of time
you're just [ __ ] dialed in ready
once we start the camera you're like
launching on ukraine you're [ __ ]
talking about
warsaw russia i'm like dude this guy's
like he's spitting up like two and a
half weeks of news right now
because he's been blue balling for
[ __ ] weeks she's just shaking reading
the headlines just waiting to pop is
that right you're right yeah like um you
know since the pandemic we changed our
shooting schedule because we wanted to
quarantine
for a good two weeks
and then we come back together and it's
like because no one left the house we
should be good right whatever
and that became our new shooting
schedule we used to shoot once a week
well we used to shoot multiple times a
week when we had multiple channels
um so i got used to that out of
necessity right
and then i actually realized this about
a couple months ago i was like you know
what i think this is taking a toll on my
mental and emotional health because i
was so used to seeing
people that i worked with every [ __ ]
day
talking to a group and i'm a i'm an
extrovert right like i need a team i
need like people to bounce back with
and then so like hannah the other day
was like i'm not [ __ ] good enough
and i'm all like
[Laughter]
you're an introvert you would have no
accent change jesus but she's mad dude
she's american bro yeah she's valley
girl and [ __ ] she could be a monk by
herself [ __ ] drawing and sewing
clothes and
not need any human to speak that's my
nicki right and then she's like i'm all
that she needs that like for [ __ ]
social talk and then she talks to her
friends back at home
so i'm like for me i'm like i didn't
realize how much of that uh team
camaraderie and work and specifically it
can't just be hanging with people i have
to be working actively toward a goal or
thinking about something productive with
the group
so i'm like if i don't do that man [ __ ]
dude by the time i'm here i'm like i
can't wait to talk to you guys yeah yeah
yeah
pretty funny but you're the same too oh
for sure no that's why i think i picked
up on it so fast because i know that
about myself already and i was like oh i
see this and joe because you're like
[ __ ] mad libsing all the recent news
[ __ ] that happened just trying to just
like in our first video i was like oh i
i reckon i see you bro i see you blue
balls
hella blue balls man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you